what started out was skipping meals
because i wanted to cut back has turned
into
an eating disorder so i i now see a
specialist on a weekly basis to try and
keep me from rolling off a ledge
the cost of living crisis is personal
for anne
a degenerative condition means she
relies on electricity to move it powers
her wheelchair two mobility hoists even
her bed i can't say well i'll i'll spend
today a mobile i won't move around the
house
um so these things stay on charge all
the time and i
i cannot cut back on their their use and
they have
quite a significant increase
in increase to our energy bill
that bill's already increased from 82 to
140 pounds a month
and a national insurance hike is about
to cut her husband's take-home pay it's
just a it's just a precipice isn't it
it's not
um it's not gradual it's just everything
is going to happen in april the council
tax rise will occur as well
and
i don't know where the money is going to
come from up to 15 million households
will be affected when energy prices
increased by an estimated 50 percent and
the government is now under pressure to
drop a plan 10
rise in national insurance also due in
april not least because inflation in
household costs hit the poorest hardest
new figures from the office for national
statistics show housing including water
electricity and gas accounts for 18 of
the income of the poorest families but
just 10 percent of highest earners
the lowest income households meanwhile
spend 10 percent of their incomes on
transport while that figure has grown to
16
for the richest
and food also accounts for a larger
share of the poorest income at 13 of
monthly costs compared to 10
for high earners
the government says it will act to
protect the most vulnerable but for many
the emergency is already here
it's terrifying it's it's
it's a really scary place to be
i don't know what the future is going to
be like
paul kelso sky news in nottingham